good afternoon
and welcome to this overview and
scrutiny committee
i'm councillor alistair mccraw and i'm
chairing the meeting today
the meeting has been called as the
petition organizer has requested that
overview and scrutiny
review the steps the council has taken
in respect of validating
his petition overview and scrutiny
are asked to review the steps the
council has undertaken
and establish whether the correct
procedure was followed
in line with the council's petition
scheme
the chair will also detail at the
appropriate time what is outside the
scope
of the review and therefore will not be
discussed
now i'd just like to go through some
domestic arrangements first of all can i
remind you that microphones should be
turned off
when not in use that you do not
interrupt other speakers
and if you're attending the meeting to
speak and you persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure mobile phones are either
on silent or switched off
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and by entering this meeting as a
speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council
and to possible use of those images and
sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
item three on the agenda is the
apologies for absence and substitutions
uh past the governance officer thank you
chair we have
no apologies received we have a full
committee today thank you very much
item four is to receive uh declarations
of pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest
by
members are there any such to declare
okay so now item five i'd like to
introduce the members of the committee
apart from myself
these are councillor sean dawson
councillor jane gould
councillor katherine grandin councillor
mary mclaren
councillor adrian osborne we won't be
undergoing a roll call
since we're all here uh now ask the uh
under sorry we now have to introduce the
officers in attendance
these will be john robinson the
corporate manager for governance and
civic office
henrietta holloway the senior governance
officer and clerk to this committee
and emily ewell the monitoring officer
next i should introduce mr morelli mr
morelli the lead petitioner
and those members of sudbury town
council who will be addressing the
committee today
so mr morelli welcome to this committee
uh councillor jack owen the mayor of
sudbury
and councillor suez uh sudbury town
councillor and not
coincidentally a baber district
councillor
so we come to the review itself
now the review process
um requires us to have a protocol
the protocol has been exhaustively
prepared based upon
previous practices in regulatory and
licensing
committees with reference to other
protocols adopted to ensure
that everybody is quite clear as to who
will speak
what will happen when it will happen and
to be
ensure that everybody has had a fair
opportunity to
to present a case and to ask questions
before we can make any recommendations
uh as to our purpose so you have the
protocol before you
that protocol is agenda item four on the
papers that's the physical papers
um it's entitled protocol for reviewing
petitions validation process
has everybody had a chance to review
that protocol
and do they clearly understand the
meaning of the protocol
okay can i ask for a proposer to adopt
the protocol for the purpose of this
meeting
can you raise a hand please
okay i have councillor grandin are you
proposing councillor grandin
i'll second it yes i'm happy to do that
okay i have councillors dawson angel
pushing to second but uh that's fine
we'll take uh councillor ghouls whose
hand was raised you don't mind
councillor grandin proposes councillor
gould seconds
uh at this point we would now go to the
modern gov uh there's no point in
debating this unless
no there's no point in debating this
let's be frank we now go to the modern
voting system if members can access the
top of the agenda the plus button
and i'll ask the governance officer to
carry out the
vote to adopt the protocol
yes chair if members can go to the app
the voting is in progress if you go to
the blue line
so chair that is six votes for the
protocol
thank you very much henrietta okay so we
now come then
to the corporate manager for governance
and civic office who will detail the
process
for the validation of petitions and the
process taken
in the instance of the validation of mr
morelli's petition
uh jan robinson uh will be you'll have
five minutes to provide your statement
after which members of the committee
will be able to ask questions offer
jan over to you thank you chair um you
have before me
before you my report that details the
validation process of petitions
i'm not going to go through the whole of
that report but i would like to
highlight the following key points
the council does not have a statutory
requirement to provide a petitions
process
but chooses to have one because it does
welcome the view of its residents
and recognises it is a method where they
can raise their concerns
the council adopted the model petitions
policy that was formulated by the now
amalgamated department of the dclg
and confirmed in the local democracy
economic development and construction
act 2009
a number of other councils have also
adopted this model petition schemes we
are not the only council that sets out
these requirements our petition scheme
is clearly set out in the constitution
under part 3 paragraph
2.2 and lists the criteria that the
petition must meet
to ensure that the petition is valid
mr morelli's petition was assessed by
the committee officer and was rejected
for validation because the full address
of the persons
supporting the petition had not been
submitted as detailed in part three
paragraph 2.2 where it clearly states
that this is a
requirement of the petitions process and
is advised also in the check form
example attached to the petitions
process
it is important that council validates
each petition to ensure that petitioners
live
work or study in the area and that the
petition is genuine
it is also essential that council has
the full name and address of the
petitioners so it's able to contact them
to provide them with any further
information
regarding the petition or if the council
wishes to consult with the petitioners
further
this cannot be done from a postcode
provision of the full name and address
also enables the council to be able to
validate the petition
to avoid any fraudulent submissions that
may result in the council taking a
decision
based on incorrect representation and
incorrect information
it is also important that the validation
process
is consistent and in line with our
council procedures
once the committee officer realized that
he was unable to validate the petition
he consulted with myself as the deputy
monitoring officer and immediately wrote
to mr morelli explaining
that a postcode did not provide
sufficient detail for due diligence to
be carried out
this approach is consistent with other
petitions that we have also rejected on
the same ground
a further complication was not all
petitioners had endorsed all three
issues and the signification
count was different different for each
of those issues
this could lead to confusion and
misrepresentation and this was also
explained to mr morelli
the committee officer offered advice and
assistance mr early on how to enable the
petition to be validated so that it
could be actioned
mr morelli was signed posted to the
petition scheme as well which enables
the petition to be completed
electronically
for convenience and also to comply with
the current covered lockdown procedures
the lead petitioner contacted the
council to say he was not prepared to
provide 20 names and addresses to
validate the petition
at this point and recognizing the work
and huge effort that the mr morelli had
undertaken
to collect all the signatures mr morelli
was invited to the
next full council meeting to address the
council on the parking element of his
petition
this being the only element of the
petition that was yet to be resolved
while the council applauds the work mr
morelli has carried out to capture
public feeling and recognizes his strong
feelings on the subject
and those of our residents the council
must follow the rules with its within
its own constitution and apply a fair
consistent process
when validating petitions across the
board
as the corporate manager for government
specific office and the deputy
monitoring officer that oversees this
process
i am satisfied that the council did
follow this process correctly
in an impartial fair and consistent
manner
although the council was not able to
validate the petition in its current
form the council has worked hard to
ensure that mr rarely had the ability
to address full council to air the views
of the residents
this would have been the same outcome if
the petition had been validated
thank you chair
thank you very much jan for that uh
presentation
i'll now invite members if they have any
questions they would like to ask
um of the um
of the officer can i just point out
could i ask members who are
not speaking uh not involved in debate
if they could turn their cameras off
it's just a matter of bandwidth
we have at least one member who has
difficulties today
thank you very much so members over to
you have you any questions
for the uh corporate manager
councillor mclaren thank you
thank you chair jan there's one or two
things that as i was reading it
i didn't find very clear so
if you don't mind i just
within the um petition process
it talks about name and addresses i
understand that
but then we get or work or
study can you just explain
i don't does a petitioner have to put
the name and address regardless of where
they live
yes they do so any you can be
anybody can um start a petition they
don't even have to be
18 years of age they have to live work
or study in the area but um the
requirement is that they provide a full
name and address
now if i don't live in the area
um but i've given you my address you
you are able to access through that
through
which which sort of um electoral role
or council tax payment we wouldn't
if if that was the case we wouldn't ex
be able to access through the electoral
roll
um possibly but we could write to you um
to check that um
you know that you you are actually who
you are and living at that address so
that would apply in those incidences and
would
and would you access the the workplace
or the place of study just to check that
i'm who i say i am
not necessarily the workplace or study
we would look at the address and you
would
you know we would possibly write to a
selection of of those petitioners
um to ask them if they worked or study
if their
address was outside of the area
so i'm sorry my cousin mclaren you
continue i just wanted a bit
um one of the other questions was what
constitutes an area of the council
so it is the baber area that we're
talking about
so as long as i live within that yes
okay
that's fine um
in 3.1 b um
it talks about circumstance
when an ordinary petition
can go to the council for debate for
validation
this would be on page 16 for uh people
looking at the papers
yes so it defines the types of petition
yeah yeah
so yes sorry cancer no no no
john and i wasn't giving you a chance to
reply
it was just that in what circumstance
then
as that's written in what circumstance
would that happen
so an ordinary petition that reaches a
thousand valid
signatories um which have been validated
would be reported to
and debated at that meeting of the
council right however
if the subject has been debated already
in this
in the year beforehand we would not do
that because
there's no you know no point absolutely
going for a debate on council when
that debate has already taken place okay
i understand that thank you very much
john thank you chair
uh just for clarity i note that the
template in appendix b
of the petition scheme does include a
relevant box for
live work or study so that the the
clarity can be sought
yeah okay uh next i have counselor gould
councillor gould your hands gone down
again
sorry i was muted do beg your pardon um
i've got a couple of questions here
the first one on page 14
which is the petition scheme it is on um
2.2 again it does say the name
address or place of work or study
which i found was just a bit ambiguous
um and i was just wondering whether
for me when i read that i took it to be
that
it's the name because there's a comma um
address or place of work or study
um so it could either be presumably your
personal address or the address of your
place of work or study
yes that would suffice actually yeah yes
so it doesn't have to necessarily be the
address of your residence it could be
the address
of your place of work or study yes but
nevertheless it needs
an address and it needs an address where
we can contact you this
is the key point that's the key thing um
and my second question is this um
the petition scheme was actually adopted
by council
on the 19th of march 2019 is it
revisited annually to be
not re-adopted but to just be looked at
and
taken down off the shelf and make sure
that it's still fit for your purpose
yes councillor so in within our
constitution we have a duty to review
our constitution every year in 2019
we've done a
line by line review and that review is
carried out by
the constitution working group which is
a cross-party
um group of councillors and we literally
go through the constitution line by line
to ensure
that we have everything up to date
because things do change and
um you know we we may need to to
do some changes those changes then come
to council for council to approve
did you say that happens annually we we
have
we're duty bound to do it annually but
we've done a full review back in 2019 so
we could do a light touch review
um which is just going through and
checking the constitution working group
there may be some changes
some of the recent changes are obviously
around how holding virtual meetings
but a line by line review was taken
undertaken back in 2019
by the constitution working group so
presumably if anybody felt that
any of the constitution needed a
slightly more in-depth um
what's the word assessment between the
in-depth reviews
there is a mechanism for that to happen
yes they can write to the monitoring
officer who would
um look at the case and if they felt
that it was justifiable we would
obviously convene a meeting of the
constitution working great
lovely thank you very much thank you
that's all mr chair for me thank you
just as a member of the last
constitution working group i can assure
members that it was extensive multiple
meetings
were held um at a time when it was
face-to-face we literally went through
every line now then uh councillor dawson
i have next
um yes janet just knows you can clarify
for me am i correct in understanding
um when someone gives their postcode for
an address
uh like mine for instance ip75dz
number five is my house number and dz is
the street
um it is not the same for all these
postcodes that would be on
that it goes to the house it's not an
area
so we would be able to identify quite
easily each address
because every individual's postcode is
clearly different
it doesn't go directly to the house so
it could it would go to a group of
houses in that street
the postcode does not just apply to one
address
does in some circumstances but in others
you can have
for instance where i live my postcode
applies to eight houses within
the close that i live so would that not
be
reasonable um know if we've got the name
of the person
and and and in here um
it says quite clearly um
that you want to check
um that they're validated the address is
if you had the name and the postcode
surely that would be sufficient no it's
not sufficient because as i say we
we haven't got the officer resource to
comb streets looking for people's names
some people because of the villages that
we live in there's families that live
along the same street which confuses
matters as well but the other issue the
more important issue is that we need the
full name and address so that we can
contact
the petitioners if we need to so that's
the the reason you know the main reason
is so that we
are able to contact those petitioners
sorry so does that mean then with these
addresses you've got
um you've checked them we check a a a
we take a sample
i just i just point out that as a former
postman
a postcode um can cover 20 or more
addresses in some instances and they're
not always in the same street
uh the postcode system is not um as
all-encompassing
as people might think and uh for that
reason letters are often misdirected
but that's just a personal observation i
have councillor grand enough
sorry i haven't finished oh sorry
counselor dawson my apologies
i was rudely interrupted again
no um no but i mean if we're taking a
sample
i don't quite understand i mean we do
this in businesses
um why if the if you thought
that you could just check if it was
eight or ten houses
um if the intention
is just exactly the same as if someone
wrote down and put fraudulent address i
mean
so we we we checked to make sure that
they're not fraudulent and the people
are
who they are but as i said before the
most important fact is that we have the
people's name and address so that we can
contact them if we need to
okay thank you okay counselor
grandin
thank you thank you chair um i hope um
i'm not repeating something or that
someone else has already said because my
technical issues i may have missed
but i'm wondering going back to 2.2
again
whether there could be considered a bit
of ambiguity
in that address does not say the word
full
in front of it if it said full address
then there would be complete clarity
um where it just says address
some people might especially as you know
when we have to validate ourselves quite
often when we make
um calls to organizations we get asked
for our postcode and so on
quite often nowadays people think of
their postcode
as their address without the word full
in front of the word address do you
think that could be leaving
ourselves open to the kind of situation
that has arisen
um counselor a postcode
um to me is not is not the name and
address
an address and then
you know addresses the street and the
town or or the village that you live in
so um okay you know there may
there could possibly be um an amendment
that we could make to put full name and
address
but it does quite clearly ask for the
name and address and it does on the form
attached to it and also in um
the other part of the um
the actual template for the petition as
well
that template and the form always don't
say the word full
so so it's sort of the same
situation so i think we're almost
leaving ourselves open
to this type of situation arising and
and it having being said that this has
happened before
maybe that's something that we may need
to look at
then um so that so
yeah so that we can stop it happening
perhaps in the future
we can certainly take that away um
counselor to to have a look at if we
need to to tighten up
the wording on there um yeah yes
thankful yeah thank you
thank you councillor brandon i'd just
like to note at this point and
i don't know if i can phrase this as a
question to jan but uh
am i not correct in thinking that the
word must
is used if the word full is not in
under 2.2 petitions submitted to the
council
must include the following and the word
must
is also used in the sample petition and
i think
at another point within the petition
scheme yes appendix a
it must meet the council's petition
scheme requirements
this use of the word must does seem to
me to be um
well quite straightforward it must
a postcode everybody knows that address
perhaps not everybody knows their
postcode
by correcting my understanding jan so
must you know is a it's a term that we
use quite a lot in the constitution and
it does
mean as it says must if there was any um
ambiguity around that we would have put
may um
rather than must but because the wording
is must there is no leeway really
it's got to be the full name address
thank you that's that was the point i
wish to find out
okay there are no other questions from
any members are there in any
so i will now um
invite mr morelli to summarize
his views on why the steps taken to
validate his petition
were inadequate mr morelli you have five
minutes
to uh summarize these reasons and uh
i'll then invite the sudbury town
councillors to speak
and then i'll invite questions from uh
members for yourself if that's okay all
right
thank you chair as members of this
committee may be aware
in the run-up to this meeting i learned
that the monitoring officer took a much
narrower view than myself
on the remit of the review to be carried
out by this committee
because of the limited remit which this
committee has now been advised that it
has i'm unsure of the committee
through no fault of its own will be able
to conduct a full and fair review of my
petition's rejection
in addition to have the same people who
oversaw baber's refusal to accept my
petition
the monitoring officer and the deputy
monitoring officer be advising the
committee on what it is and
isn't allowed to do in its review and
what is and isn't in its remit
seems likely to me to be a conflict of
interest however
with this dispute over the committee's
remit and all the other roadblocks upon
roadblocks that i've faced in appealing
baby's decision
it is easy to lose sight of the most
important part of all of this
the actual points raised within the
petition democracy is damaged when
processes become more important than
issues themselves
as has happened here in the dispute over
my petitions validity
these issues will affect real people
from the businesses that would be harmed
with the rash removal of free parking
from sudbury
to the heritage that could be lost if
the bellevue land sale is not handled
with care
to the most vulnerable in our community
that will suffer from babies plans to
move the customer access point to
sudbury library
and staff it for only two full days a
week this is why i find it disgraceful
that baber
instead of focusing on the actual issues
at hand has continuously placed barrier
after barrier
in the way of allowing the issues at the
heart of all of this to be properly
heard at all
this is why i'm pushing for this
petition to be accepted
so that these issues which will affect
real people can be properly heard and
debated at bay before council
baby district council are fully aware of
the strength of feeling that has been
transmitted through this petition
whether they choose to accept it or not
they know that over one
thousand six hundred signatures have
been obtained during a time in which
sudbury was in tier four
and then lockdown restrictions to quote
an email to baba from the chair of the
sudbury society
in which they comment about the
individual sheets of paper that make up
this petition
you can throw them away burn them or
just disregard them
but the opposition they represent won't
go away and you know it
i'd like to take the opportunity to
address some inaccuracies and confusing
statements in report
brp 21 from the monitoring officer
presented to this committee
with the time limit i have for this
speech i'm not able to respond to every
statement in the report that i object to
so i will respond to the ones that i
believe are the most inaccurate
paragraph 4.7 in this report states that
signatories names and addresses are
checked against the open electoral
register
however this method of signature
verification is still possible when only
postcodes are provided
even without full addresses the
postcodes can still be matched against
the electoral role
it is not explained within the report
why such a method of verification is not
possible
with only postcodes provided paragraph
4.11 states that
quote the validation of the full name
and address of each signatory
also enables the council to avoid
accepting any signatures which may have
been spread
submitted fraudulently however no
information is given for how this would
be possible at all
and for why it is not possible with
postcodes instead of full addresses
paragraph 4.13 states that quote not all
of the petitioners had endorsed all
three issues contained in the petition
this statement is misleading and seems
to deliberately lack context
faber district council know full well
that only 11 signatories
signed a partial petition this is in
comparison to the 1662 people
that signed the petition as is without
the context i accept that this could be
seen as a problem but when the context
is provided
it becomes clear that this issue is so
minor as to be completely irrelevant
paragraph 4.17 states and strongly
implies
that my invitation to attend full
council would have produced the same
outcome as quote
if the petition had been validated this
is patently false
it was made clear to me that if i
attended the full council debate on the
hadley car parking petition
car parking would be the only matter
allowed for discussion
not any of the two remaining issues on
my petition
if my petition is accepted i will be
able to address a full council debate on
all three issues
it is therefore clear to see that the
opportunity i was given to address full
council
would not quote have been the same
outcome end quote
as if this petition had not been
rejected
to close i mentioned earlier in my
speech that i was unsure if the
committee would be able to conduct a
fair review of my petitions rejection
with the remit that it has been told
that it has however
i still hold out hope i would urge this
committee
to recommend to full council that this
petition be accepted so that the issues
raised
all of which will affect real people can
be properly debated
by the full council and thank you chad
be happy to
answer any questions thank you very much
mr morelli for your presentation
and a well-constructed argument if i
might move on then to the
sudbury town councillors who've
expressed a wish to speak
these would be first councillor uh owen
the mayor of sudbury and councillor
heirs
councillor owen uh you have two minutes
if you'd like to address the committee
thank you chair for affording me the
opportunity to speak in support of
thomas morelli's petition
covering the sudbury advice centre the
sale of bellevue house
and adjacent land and the introduction
of car park charges across baber
i will try not to go over the same areas
covered by thomas
but with such a narrow remit that may be
proved difficult
whilst understanding the need for a
consistent approach to the presentation
of a petition
i i believe a consistent level of
circumstances
could assist in that process now i'm not
blaming the committee
baba district council or the monitoring
officer for the circumstances that we
have been fighting
over the last 11 months but i'm
suggesting that trying to abide by the
rules at the time when
faced with a pandemic that's resulted in
a total lockdown
across the entire country with
instructions by the government to stay
indoors unless absolutely necessary
and a time of celebrating christmas
means people's minds are elsewhere
coupled with a different timetable for
the three issues
contained within the petition does not
lead
to an easy environment for democracy to
flourish
some time earlier last year baby
district council carried out a survey to
seek guidance on the public views
of the future development of market hill
in sudbury
at that time it was suffice for those
taking part
in the survey to just put their postcode
in their response
petitions and surveys are to give the
public an opportunity to express their
feelings
over a chosen topic or topics one is
conducted by an authority
who are seeking to change things the
other is conducted by a member of the
public
who opposes the changes suggested we
need to apply consistency
it should make no difference who is
conducting the survey
stroke petition in conclusion chair i
feel that a level of common sense
should apply bearing in mind the timing
of the announce
announcing on the three issues i'm
nearly finished here
the extraordinary circumstance of the
pandemic that i mentioned
earlier and the enthusiasm of the young
person who took it upon himself
to go such to such extraordinary lens
gained so many signatures
in seeking out democracy 662 local
citizens say
in such a short time period i urge you
to recommend
to overturn the decision check thank you
thank you very much councillor and i
don't think anybody on the committee
doubts the effort
and the uh extraordinary degree of work
done
by mr morelli it's in fact praised
within the report itself
i now turn to councillors if you'd like
to speak you have two minutes counsellor
ayers
thank you chair um what more can i say
apart from i think thomas is wonderful
he'll make a wonderful lawyer and i
think he's brilliant
had we not have been in lockdown i would
have been outside the town hall
collecting full names and addresses
this was impossible so i'm sorry we
haven't got the full addresses
but my more worried about what does this
say to our young people
is this democracy no it's bureaucracy
combine me as far as i'm concerned
how many times when you have a petition
do you actually check on the addresses
i actually offered with the electoral
role to go through
and find the names and addresses so i
really do feel that this should
be listened to and i know that you have
your reasons
and i can understand them but this is
during a pandemic we have got to be
flexible
that's all i'm going to say apart from
well done thomas we are
very proud of you sudbury is very proud
of you thank you
thank you very much councillor ayers at
this point
uh we come to the next part of the
protocol uh
council dawson did you have something
you wish to ask or i think we're
actually not at that point we're coming
to
the point now where we i will invite
questions from members
for mr morelli uh is that something
you'd like to address
uh yes please thank you then councillor
dawson followed by
councillor grandin yes thomas uh thank
you very much warren hadley we're
delighted with what you did and
you know i recognize it's uh very hard
work and fully supported what you do
uh or what you did rather but can i just
ask you why it's not really clear in
here why you weren't prepared to
think of argument and to get this
through to provide
20 names and addresses to validate the
petition
because it's you know you might not have
agreed with it but for the sake of
getting into council
if it had been me i would have just kind
of got them and also
you then sort of went on to decline the
invitation to speak
so you know uh it's a shame really
because you had two sort of quite good
opportunities it's almost like you sort
of cut off your nose despite your face
and as i said you know i fully support
this petition so i'm just wondering why
you didn't really do that and it's not
clear in here
all right so um yes um i'd be happy to
answer those questions
firstly um it's a shame that i wasn't
able to mention it during my speech
because of the time constraints
but with regards to the 20 names and
addresses i feel like
um especially in the report um it's
it again hasn't been put across with the
fullest of context
um because this is something i checked
early on if i submitted if i collected
and submitted 20 names and addresses and
i wasn't averse to doing it
but if i did it would have then been
treated as a petition of
only 20 names and addresses and this was
something i clarified
with the committee's officer who emailed
me to inform me of
this and this yeah this i actually did
i believe on the 13th yes because this
was when
um before i sent my original letter and
um one of the sudbury town councillors
who co-signed my original letter wanted
me to clarify that but yes
if i collected 20 names and addresses it
would have only been treated as a
petition of 20
meaning it wouldn't in my understanding
and from everything i've heard it would
then
not have been eligible to go to full
council for a debate
um so in that respect uh there was no
point in getting 20 names and addresses
or 20 addresses rather because it would
still not have gone to full council
and can i can i intervene at this point
sean i do apologize for this but it
actually is relevant to mr morelli's
response
can we clarify with officers if that is
indeed the case
that it would not have resulted in a
debate at council
is that the case or is it not um chair
thank you for that
um so just to clarify if the um position
petition had been validated at 26
uh signatures it would then have become
a valid petition
and we would have had to take action on
it so um
and that action would have been dealt
with by the portfolio holder and
the assistant director and it would be
for them to decide
how to take that forward the petition if
it was validated would have been
reported to council
but not debated but the debate was
taking place
anyway and mr morelli would have had the
opportunity to address the council
as he would have done in a full petition
thus achieving his objective
yeah instance
is that correct the portfolio holder
they wouldn't have
um allowed it to go to full council
though because she's against it
it had been agreed in my understanding
and reading of the emails throughout
this whole period
yeah but that's because there was 1600
but if
i think what thomas is saying here is
had he had 20 signatures
um the portfolio however being liz
malvesey would have
rejected it wouldn't she because she's
against it so she would have decided
no but she would have decided it
couldn't have gone to full council for
debate
no no it wouldn't have been a matter for
the portfolio holder i've read the
emails very closely because i was
sorry just what jan just said though
that's what i thought i mean i thought
it had already been agreed i wanted to
clarify this point because i think it's
important
can you sorry you're saying something
completely different to what jan's
saying now
i think i'm trying to get some clarity
in the point perhaps jan could comment
upon that
that the eventual result whether the
regardless of status or anything else
would have been mr morelli able to
address the council
during a debate on at least one of the
three subjects that were contained
within his petition
is that a correct understanding mr
morelli was offered the opportunity to
come to council
as our guest to um debate the um
to speak to council during the debate
about parking
the ordinary petition status just to
clarify
once the petition becomes an ordinary
petition i.e
it's validated it would then go through
our petitions process
so it would be down to the assistant
director
and senior leadership team in in
consultation with the portfolio holder
on how they dealt with that petition
um and it you know it will be down to
them they but they could take
any action and one of those actions may
have been a council debate
um you know it's very ruled out
and again on the other hand if they're
against it um
if i may finish sorry if they're against
it they would probably not do that
well they would need to have a good
reason why not to do it and
also they would have to take into
account the number of signatures
that were obviously on that validated
petition
and again i just want to clarify this
point because again i read
all the emails whilst they were being
produced and in fact i believe that
the leader had made this offer himself
that the
opportunity to address that would be
done so i don't think the cabinet
members
view would necessarily have come into
play it certainly didn't appear that way
from reading the emails whilst they were
being sent backwards and forwards
i do apologize for interrupting you
councillor dawson but i thought it was
important to draw this point out
would you like to continue um yes so
sorry thomas so your understanding was
that
obviously it wouldn't go to full council
if you only put 20 addresses in i think
um well yes um i mean this i think what
sort of happened here is there's been a
confusion and this discussion has just
been had
right now there's been a bit of
confusion between the
right the statutory right i would have
had to and
the right there would have been for a
full council debate had it been a
validate
classed as a validate petition of over a
thousand signatures
and the offer that was made to me to
attend
the debate on the hadley car parking
petition and from listening just now
it's clear that those two have been
confused and i was actually about
i was about to come on to that on the
second prom of your question but i'll
just answer that now
um yes so i was offered to speak at full
council
purely with regards to hadley car
parking um
the corporate manager for the governance
and civic office
gave me a ring uh gave me a phone call
on the same day as uh councillor john
ward's email
that counselor mccraw refers to there
offering me the opportunity to speak at
this
full council debate but it was made
clear to me that it would only be on
hadley car parking it would only be on
car parking
um i would not be able to address
the bellevue landscape i would not be
able to address the closure of the
customer access point
and frankly um and this is i'll admit
this is a personal consideration
but i considered it would be a
disservice of my
of what is now effectively my duty
representing these
petition signatories to go ahead with
this because it would mean that only
one of the three issues would be heard
and um
uh yes and just to follow back on what's
been said
on if i'd submitted 20 names and
addresses it it would then
from what i understand it and from what
the corporate managers just said
it would then be classed as an ordinary
petition
of 20 signatures so um as far as i
could see and from everything that was
told to me before this meeting
um from the 13th of january from the
12th to the
12th of january onwards it would not
go to full council for a debate
i would agree with you probably okay um
i mean whether it's statutory or de
facto
okay we can argue the difference there
but uh
the de facto position might have existed
councillor grandin
thank you thank you chair um yes i am
chairman of the council um thomas and i
was very disappointed also that
you didn't wish to come to full council
when you were given the opportunity
um i want to emphasize that
in discussions i had with the governance
and monitoring officers um
we were very mindful of the fact that
you had put so much effort
into collecting the signatures and we
particularly were keen
to um um
give democracy the chance to speak
um we we saw democracy as the most
important thing here
and so we were bending over backwards
really to try and give you the
opportunity to speak despite the fact
that um factually the
um petition hadn't been
properly carried out so despite
that you know we wanted you we
we really wanted you to come to the
council to speak to give you the
opportunity to represent
sudbury and so you know it was a little
bit
disappointing really that that you
didn't want to take up that offer
and you there might have been a later
opportunity
for you to talk about bellevue house
because that
matter was
wasn't coming up at that day and the
access point had already been decided
so there were clear reasons why and it
was all explained to you
um and the other thing i just wanted to
make clear
as well is that um for
everyone that's been dealing with you
really admires
what you're doing and so you know that's
why
that's another reason why we wanted to
give you this opportunity
so you know we it wasn't for
wanting to make this happen we wanted
um to to for you to have this moment
what can i what's your feeling did you
not feel as if we were bending over
backwards to give you the
the chance well that first of all thank
you for
your incredibly kind words um and
yes uh i'll address what you said in the
audience said it
um so first of all i you mentioned
well yeah you used phrase bending over
backwards to do this and
i appreciate this yeah i mean um it was
certainly
um i recognize obviously that it's not
an ordinary thing to do
to allow someone like me with a
what is essentially an invalidated
petition to talk to full council in this
way and a dressful council in this way
but from my perspective i
i didn't think i'd be able to sort of
per personally reconcile with it because
you've said just now and it's um that
bill you might come up later and i might
have had a chance to discuss on the
other issues later on
um first of all that wasn't told to me
it was just
as i as i recall it was just car parking
do you want us uh we'd like to invite
you to speak on this hadley car parking
petition um uh and it no
and it certainly wasn't mentioned either
of the other issues except for the fact
i wouldn't be allowed to discuss
them at the full council meeting and
that and this was as i said earlier
this offer was made by the corporate
manager and a phone call to myself and
then after that phone call i got a
further email from
the corporate manager and then i believe
i got an email from councillor ward at
some point but
i don't believe that's relevant but
anyway um and so i suppose
and yeah so from my own personal
perspective i didn't think i'd be able
to reconcile it with
what i said was is effective was slash
is
still my duty to the petitioners to
ensure their voice is heard
and um in respect of do i think you've
bent over
backwards enough um to use that phrase
um
um certainly um not yourself
personally as um oh well certainly i
don't have any
issue with what you've done personally
as chair of the council i think
um you're very gracious in allowing me
the opportunity to speak at full council
but and i mentioned this in my letter um
to the committee
of the 31st of january there's a um um
last year in june or july i believe it
was braintree
district council um used their
discretion to allow a petition that had
under a thousand deemed to have under a
thousand valid signatures to be debated
by the full council and in the same way
i it seems to me and i believe that
david district council here
would have been a would have been well
within their authority to
say all right well look we've um
received this petition it doesn't have
the full addresses
but given the circumstances we're in
we're going to
allow it to proceed to a full council
debate um and so in terms of um giving
democracy a chance to speak i believe
that that would have
been the best outcome and hence that's
why i'm urging the committee to
recommend
that this petition be accepted um the
next thing um
i'm just reading through my notes here
um yes so
um and in terms of
yeah and in terms of the position where
i was at um
on the 13th of january when i received
this offer to attend full council
um it just seemed to me to
to be not not good enough and again i'm
not saying that to you personally
of course but just in terms of general
response
from the council to the petition given
the circumstances
and given the number of signatures it
obtained i hope that answers your
question
let me know please tell me if i've
missed something
okay counselor brandon yes thank you
although i guess you did freeze a bit so
i hope i
understood all all you said um
completely but
um by inviting you to council on
on that day in january it would have
actually put you in the same position
as if your petition had been
validated because it would have given
you that opportunity to speak on one of
the items and the other items
weren't um scheduled anyway
um could do would you mind chair if i
responded on that
i have no objection thank you um i don't
believe it would be factually the same
outcome because um regardless of the
state of whether the issues themselves
had been decided or hadn't been decided
yes the um customer access point for
instance i believe that
the decision to close um relocate the
customer
access point from the town hall was made
by cabinet in december i think it was
but in terms but i don't think that
should
prevent if a petition comes in with over
a thousand signatures
um i don't believe that that the fact
that a decision has already been made
should be enough to disqualify a debate
and um yes they weren't on the agenda
for that meeting but if they if the
petition had been allowed
to have a debate as would be normal for
petitions over a thousand signatures
they would have been put on the agenda
and they would have
been debated whereas at the moment um
full council as i understand it has only
really had the chance
to speak on one of the issues which is
car parking and that was only due to
another petition
that came in with over a thousand
signatures
right we're now getting into governance
issues that are probably not the matter
we are here to discuss today
i will i'm more than happy mr morelli by
the way to discuss those with you at a
later date
um however for the moment i'll move on
to councillor gould who seems to have
her hand up and then i'll go on back to
councillor dawson i have a question
myself but i'll reserve that for later
castle thank you um i i almost feel
we're going round and round in circles
here
um and when i i'm trying to unpick the
different threads
um and i think it seems to me one one of
the things is
we're sticking on these 20 signatures
somehow thomas
um and i think probably councillor
grandin has said what i was thinking of
saying which is that
um the whole council was looking forward
to you coming
and to hearing what you had to say and
whilst i do appreciate that it was just
the car parking that would have been the
the issue in question
um it would have been good to have heard
you so my question was
sort of around why you you decided not
to come and i think you've already
answered that
but i did just want to sort of just put
my point again
um and also i think um
if if the 20 signatures had come in it
would have then gone i'm just trying to
remember what
jan robinson said um in terms of the
direction of travel of this petition
then but it wouldn't have been down to
the cabinet member
um to have refused it it wouldn't have
been her choice to have refused it just
because
she didn't like the content there would
have been checks and balances and it
would have gone through
um the system in a way with its checks
and balances so
i think i would just like to register
that i don't agree
that the account the the cabinet member
member councillor malvizi would have
actually turned it down because she
didn't agree with the content
so we are into governance issues i think
um and the braintree council just from
on my final point as all of this has
been
um going through my head they actually
had the petition
in front of them it had been validated
and it just seems to me
if if and councillors um
offered to collect some addresses so if
councillors
if her offer had been timely which i
don't know whether it was or not
and you had um availed yourself of
councillor's
offer to collect the 20 signatures the
petition would have been validated
and i absolutely hear what you're saying
um
we wouldn't it would have been a 20
signature petition
but i think we all would have accepted
we all realized that you worked
incredibly hard
to get to the 1600 signatures and it
wouldn't have been
negated it would have been there in our
debate
there isn't a question there really
there's a lot of i'm trying to unpick
the threads
no that's fine um also
excuse me uh councillor mccrory you're
unmute
i didn't like to tell you alistair
because we were muted
probably the first time i've ever been
observed to be on mute
um i'd just like to say i think we're
going back over the same ground
mr morelli you've already answered the
essentials of that it's clear there is a
difference
uh can you make a brief comment and then
we'll move on to the next question
yes to add on what's being said about 20
signatures and what the government and
what the corporate manager has said to
us now
i'm looking back over the emails i've
got um it wasn't explained to me what
would really happen
after 20 signatures have been validated
and as far as i can remember
um the only uh because in
i'm just looking at a pen appendix b3
to the monitoring officer's report um
and it just says um in respect of this
it requires 20 signatures to validate it
doesn't especially specify what would
happen after that and
as far as i was concerned the main
objective was a council debate then
um quickly to respond because i
appreciate time limits on the braintree
petition thing
i'm not uh i'm quoting the braintree um
situation as proof that a council in
circumstances
can take decisions under on its own
discretion
even when it's not fully compliant so
i'm so there is slight difference in
circumstances
yeah i mean i think there's a
considerable difference one would have
been a validated
petition perhaps not of the required
number the other one was actually
quite clearly not operating according to
the petition scheme
in action in a very particular matter
that of addresses now
i'd like to go back on to councillor
mclaren and then councillor dawson do
you have a further question
yes okay council mclaren first then
thank you
chair um hello thomas
we're all very sad in some ways
that um we're here today
and listening to you um because
it would have been wonderful for us to
listen to you in full counsel but that's
already been said
one of the things that i want to ask you
when you started your petition which was
absolutely amazing and a lot of hard
work
did you actually go on the council
website
to find out what constituted
an acceptable petition
um no before starting the petition i did
not
um to give a bit of con background um
i was made aware of these issues in late
december
and was sort of trying to put the
petition together and organize
everything to do with that incredibly
short notice and time scale um i can
tell you that i
where i got the sort of idea for the
postcodes from
was on the uk government petitions
website
when you're signing a petition it asks
your postcode and so i go
i thought that's this will be it
because obviously i could i mean i and i
can still really
in terms of especially what's being said
in reports about the electoral roll see
no reason why it can't be valid but
that's that's off that's not on the
topic of the question so to answer
to answer your question no i wasn't
aware of that
at the time of starting the petition and
only became aware of it afterwards
all right so that's a bit sad really
isn't it
that um you weren't able to do that but
i think we are we do
all fully admire you for what you've
done
and um what what
what were you like when you sort of um
were invited to the council
meeting um
what what went through your mind what
did you think was going to happen
next after that um well
in terms of what would happen within the
council
um what would happen to your petition
what did you think
well i mean i guess the i mean it's the
hope of any person organizing a petition
is that
change will be made objectionable issues
will be dealt with
and um as i said i did this a very short
notice and so
um only during the organization of the
petition
i at some point found the petition
scheme obviously because that's why
we're here now
and found that okay over a thousand
signatures
it will then go to a debate of full
council and that to me it seems like the
the most the easiest way to um
um see to have a debate on the issues
and if there is going to be any change
to try
to sort of act as a stepping stone to
that change
would be a full council debate um and so
of course the primary aim was to is and
is still
to get the issues addressed and i
mentioned this in my opening speech but
then
then obviously it was also a desire to
have it debated by the full council
yeah okay thank you very much thomas
just in passing can i ask members and
participants in the meeting to note the
message box
function is here to allow help us in
technical matters not for uh
raising points or debating or discussing
in any way
uh that is not part of the meeting but
it is of course made public
uh so please desist councillor dawson
um yes this is perhaps you could clarify
um jan
on this regarding if you look at page 18
4.6 it says we will not take any action
on any petition which the strategic
director considers to be vexatious
abusive or otherwise inappropriate now
clearly this
um petition would wouldn't really fall
my understanding is into any of these um
points here and therefore um
5.1 surely that our response should have
been one of those eight points
which we haven't done which would
suggest the process hasn't been done
correctly
is this a question for jan robinson well
i'm just trying to
er to ascertain me because if this has
not been done it means the process
wasn't followed correctly which at the
moment i understand it has been
dan what's the reason that's okay
sorry can i just clarify so um because
it didn't because the petition at this
stage has not reached
petition status um it the the um
strategic director point only comes in
once it's a validated petition
it then goes to the next stage and we
look at the petition
the subjects of the petition and that's
when um the strategic director can still
rule them out as vectors and that's
normally when it's a
it's about a person it's the next stage
on okay
i think the report quite clearly states
the reason for non-validation
was not 4.6 but in fact the addresses um
and the word you know the fact the
addresses were not supplied
that was that's the magistrate alistair
for 13 years so i'm quite clear about
what it says here
because that's what i'm saying to you
what i'm what i'm saying are trying to
say is that 4.6 did not enter into the
equation
it was entirely based upon the
validation principle
of not having addressed the second stage
yes yes but
fundamentally we don't get to the second
stage if we haven't got past the first
stage
thank you thank you i have a question
myself now if i may
um and i just think to i mean i'm glad
we've had some description
of the process under which you you
address
raising the petition um not a very easy
time to raise a petition at any time
uh would you accept that had you looked
at the baba petition scheme
prior to embarking on the petition that
it might have been better
oh sorry uh sorry i didn't realize she
finished no no no no no i apologize i
should have made myself clearer
no that's fine um uh to be perfectly and
completely honest
with you before starting this petition i
didn't even realize
there's a petition scheme was something
baba had because um
there's in my eyes and it is and to a
point it's still in my eyes a petition
is just it's a concept it's not really
intrinsically something that can be set
out in a scheme and which
this is why why i say um the
the strength of feeling has been
expressed whether or not it is wish to
be accepted
and so to a point um i accept that
yes if i had looked at it and seen aura
i need full addresses
then it would mean good but on the other
hand and this is
and i accept this isn't directly
relevant here but there is a case to be
made i feel
about whether or not the requiring
addresses to be included
would have actually caused some people
who would have otherwise signed it
to not want to sign it in view of not
wanting to give their
full address um in in relation to the
support of this to the council
but that would imply then mr morelli
that that they would not wish to be
associated with
if they aren't prepared to give their
address how could their how could their
participation in the petition be
uh be verified i think we come to a
crucial point here
can i ask also if you had any advice
from outside
in preparing your petition and also how
you undertook the practical measures
of obtaining the uh signatures and
postcodes because obviously we were in
a particular particularly awkward
situation at that time
how did you go about the practicalities
of raising the petition
okay i'm just trying to your first
question i'll just one at a time
um what's that um would they want to be
associated with it i think it's more on
that point because i had
i i've been in contact several
petitioners have emailed me
who for what for one reason or another
um would one would not object to being
associated with the petition
but may fear um it sounds
weird to say but it may fear some sort
of repercussions
put it that way of being associated with
it so in terms of
what i mean i'm only i'm genuinely
surprised mr morelli i honestly
am i mean i mean i mean it wouldn't be
all of them but it's like with anything
if you ask people for lots of
information then even if they would want
to be associated with it
they'd be the more information you asked
for as with anything
the less likely they they'd want uh
a person would want to would feel up to
providing it or might just think you
know what i
i don't i'm not going to do this and um
that would appear to be people asking
for a degree of a nominee
anonymity at the same time as signing a
petition which is
also sort of counter-intuitive you can't
be both
one well um
i'm also addressing that um some people
would want to
signer would want to sign a petition to
object to an issue
but then the more sort of hoops you have
to jump through in order to
um set in order to express your views on
something
um would then be sort of a potential
um off switch to
some people who might be otherwise
supportive of it
um i'll get yeah so that that
basically and did you did you receive
any advice from people
who'd raised petitions previously did
you get any support
and how did you practically go about uh
getting the
postcodes as it happens um and the
petitioners
okay um so in relation to outside advice
um uh i i received advice from
some friends of mine i'm unsure if any
of them have ever submitted a petition
before
um i would presume that they have not
um in terms of that does that answer
that question
um sort of i don't know that we've
actually heard that that you had advice
um on the petitions and how a petition
could be carried out that's all
well i i apologize i apologize if i seem
to be pressing on this
i remind members not to use the message
box frankly it's getting
distracting um the advice i received was
mainly just
um organizational advice on how to
organize it in the first place and
and help and assistance with organizing
it i didn't get any advice
i i'm i'm pretty much certain about my
memory but i'm pretty
99 sure i didn't receive any advice on
actually what it should contain
in terms of names or addresses that's
fine and to say everybody's very
admiring of the work you've done um
literally as it appears
you know completely off the cuff um and
thank you for all your efforts
uh do you have any other sorry boom yeah
i just wanted to answer your third
question
of course yesterday that was done um so
it was done
um via leaflets hand delivered to
uh through letterboxes um this was um
when
a time when sudbury was in tier four
lockdown restrictions i believe and
of course there is a question to be
asked i guess i'll leave it as an open
question
if it's justified or not legally i
believe it was justified because
um for example um uh there was an
exception
for um it was quite vague i remember
looking at it i
covered voluntary work um but in
addition
the way i thought of it was well if you
were working for
for example a company that wanted you to
put leaflets through people's doors that
would be allowed under
um the law covering um working
during the pandemic and in terms of risk
from covid
on letters and paper put through the
door um
everything i've read it seemed seemed to
suggest it was
of minimal risk to the residents
yeah so i imagine i imagine you have a
substantial print bill and have used up
every ink cartridge in sudbury then
um yeah that was a that was a side i
apologize
um at this point if you're all willing
um
if no members have any further questions
either for mr morelli or for the
corporate
manager for governance and civic office
i'd like to ask
both parties if they have anything
further they wish to add
summarizing for maybe one minute only mr
morelli do you have anything you wish to
add
and and summarize yes so um in summary
i would say i'm doing my there are lots
of issues i raised i believe that i made
nine points in my letter to the
committee
it was not possible especially during
given the fact that i didn't have sight
of the monitoring officer's report when
writing that letter
to repeat all of them in my speech but i
would just say i
still stand by that letter and i mean
yeah and i would in particular emphasize
i know it's been discussed
that um the president
in a way set by brain through district
council on being able to take action
where a petition is non-compliant in
some way be that validation
or in that case numbers um reaffirms the
um ability and um authority of a council
to do this and i believe in this
circumstance
is clearly the right thing to do and by
extension i believe this is
what the committee should do um by um
extended authority of obviously being a
part of the council and
that is all i would say thank you thank
you very much mr morelli
uh i'd like to ask the corporate
governor uh
corporate manager for governance if you
have anything to say jan
um not too much chair but just to
reiterate that the council must follow
the rules within its own constitution
and we must apply them fairly and
consistently
across the board um i am
really um admiring of the work that mr
morelli has
carried out and um we're always there to
help
members of the public if they do need to
start a petition and we welcome them and
you know like to see them coming forward
so you know this is never
about um preventing democracy happening
but it is about making sure that we do
follow the rules of our constitution
so um that's all i have to say thank you
thank you very much jan uh but this
point then members
uh for the committee only uh we now
enter the debating period
we can now debate the issues and
principally whether we feel that the
validation process
has been followed correctly as stated
in the petition scheme uh particularly
under the matter of validations
and uh has it been followed correctly
and has the petition been dealt with
adequately under that
proviso so i have hands up from
councillors grandin and dawson
councillor grandin
thank you chair um as
i as cameron i was um
able to observe some of the actions that
took
place in attempting to validate
this petition i would say
we did everything we could to help
and that um the scheme
was followed properly from the council's
point of view
and in fact we did more than that we did
more than we needed to do to validate
it or to help help the process rather
um because we actually wanted to see
democracy done we
wanted to help and it's unfortunate i
think
had the wording of the the original
wording
being slightly different that might have
helped
but taking things as they are i think
baber district council and its officers
did everything they
could to do everything correctly and to
give
enough opportunity to miss for mr
morelli to be in the same position
as if he did have a validated
petition so i would say yes we did
everything
we could and should have done okay
councillor dawson
and i actually observed that too
um yes i would agree with that although
i support it very strongly or
petition thomas the problem here is it's
about the process and it's
i must say it's very unfortunate you
didn't um submit those 20 names
or perhaps come forward uh very
disappointing because that would have
been super to see you've done that
um but i think you know i'd like to
think perhaps in future
it's very clear what the intention was
here and to
um i think you know we katherine and
myself and councillor fraser and hadley
we did everything we could and half our
group um
supported this petition and it came down
to a few cabinet members
um who who had quite an override
you know quite more influence perhaps on
all of this
but i'd like to think that we wouldn't
perhaps be so petty
um about this business with the
addresses because a lot of people would
actually just don't want to get i mean i
certainly wouldn't want to put my
address on a petition
and i'm sure a number of other people
feel the same
um but i would support the fact that
unfortunately the process has been
followed which would mean that i would
have to vote that way but that's not to
say that you've done a fantastic job
thomas
and don't be um next time just make sure
you get all your
everything all your your dots well as
they say crossed and everything make
sure
the the procedures followed correctly
thank you thank you councillor dawson
castle gould
thank you alistair um or mr chair i
think
i would i it does seem to me that the
council has followed
the um the petition scheme um
and i would have to vote for that myself
um but but
i would just like to emphasize yet again
that i've been
really impressed with mr morelli's um
his tenacity and the way he's he's
really
um very very articulate and um
absolutely
spot on really with your arguments and i
picked up from somebody that you might
be thinking of being a lawyer
and you would make johnny good one um
but
if we feel that the petition scheme is
wanting in any way
that perhaps there might be a couple of
words we might need to add to this
section
2.2 to just make it even even more
robust
that i guess would be a recommendation
we could place somewhere
um because some of it i think is we are
where we are
and how do we avoid being in a situation
that perhaps we don't want to be in
um on on a future occasion so that would
be something that i would sort of just
float mr chair really
um and i think that's all i've got to
say
thank you very much councillor gould
councillor mclaren
thank you chair um i'd just like to say
that thomas uh i said before has done a
great job and we
respect him for that but he actually was
supported by a lot of people
who actually could have perhaps
encouraged him in the right direction
with this process and i think that is
sad that those people didn't do that
thank you chair
thank you very much council mclaren um
at this point um i have a comment i'd
like to make and um
i think it's germaine to the argument
uh at various times oh counselor osborne
you have your hand raised
and perhaps you would like to speak i'll
ask oh thank you for noticing me mr
chairman i
apologize i have had it up sometime but
you've asked
you've asked the questions that i was
going to ask first of all
i'd just like to say that um a great
admiration for mr morelli's uh
uh way forward on on dealing with this
i do feel it's unfortunate that as
uh councillor mclaren has said that um
he hadn't got the advice and also uh
the look at the uh the actual petition
that is down in the in the um
in the baby's uh ways of working instead
of
the petition that he produced that
another another
uh situation here is that um
i'm pretty understanding that he
actually delivered a lot of these
uh petitions himself or leaflets himself
which uh had the uh uh setups as we've
seen them
in in the confidential list and
unfortunately it didn't include the
address set up that had was in in the um
petitioning scheme also i'd just like to
add that actually paper is one of the
biggest carriers of
any virus or germ money is
a particular setup so he ought to have
been
a little bit more um risk averse of of
of all of that and don't forget if he's
put the
petitions uh the lethal it's through the
letter boxes those letter boxes
would also unfortunately if other people
who
have touched them to put anything
through would be exactly the same
but again i've got to support our
our officer on these on on these
questions
they're quite right the process i think
was adhered to
and i agree with the other councillors
that uh
that have spoken thank you thank you
councillor osborne
on that note uh uh excuse me council mr
morelli i'm afraid we're in debate now
so i can't be taking any more comments
at the moment i will note however that
we do
in the petition scheme have provision
for e-petitions
uh under section six uh and
officer support is available because we
encourage petitions that's why we have a
petition scheme
so for my own points and perhaps to
bring
the debate to some uh understanding a
couple of points i observed is that
the use of the electoral role and the
checking mechanism that we use by
approaching the open
electoral role the electoral role of
course is organized in street order
it is not organized in postcode order
so it's not as easy to suggest that
postcodes necessarily
would be a more efficient method in fact
they'd be
less efficient method most people have
know their address they don't
necessarily
know their postcode and the other
suggestion made
during discussion in the emails
contained within various papers is that
this has been
an arbitrary decision now the definition
of arbitrary is based on random choice
or personal
whim rather than any reason
or system we do have a system
it's our petition scheme and it should
be the guiding principle for
any petitions presented to the council
now i would agree
with the other members who've stated
that we followed our scheme
according to what it states we have
refused petitions in the past
on the basis that they have not been
valid the petition scheme is widely
publicized on our website and
would be quite reasonable just to phone
up the counselor or speak to your local
counsellor and ask
what to do i don't believe that anybody
need have any
fears of signing an address in a
petition scheme
uh what possible comeback could there be
i mean this is not the way we do things
nobody would do things that sort of way
so all i can say is i don't think we can
argue that the council have not
followed the petition adequately um
the main point i'm going to say is that
i would say that the validation process
was followed correctly
and i would propose a motion to that
effect
and the petition was dealt with
adequately
in that respect second
recommendation i believe we could
consider is
that the petition scheme only be
reviewed
um fairly soon that we go through the
petition scheme and see if there are
improvements that could be made to
wording
and i believe that would get some
support from members of this committee
i would be happy to propose those two
motions one
that the validation process was followed
correctly
and that two therefore the petition was
entitled to be
uh rejected in that sense the
officers made strenuous efforts along
with leadership to try
and address the central point whilst not
saying
that we were going to make an arbitrary
decision we didn't second point the
review
can i have a seconder for those motions
i have councillor and then captain i'm
happy to do that
councillor i'm happy today yes
um now then uh are there any counter
proposals that anybody wishes to make
is there any discussion that anybody
wishes to have
counselor brandon your hand is still up
is that a legacy
ah fine okay
thank you henry have you got that uh
entered onto the system
we have the uh let me just do
something here um could we say that the
second one was that the
baby over you and security committee
recommends to council that the council's
petition scheme
be reviewed and updated in line with the
comments made at this committee
i don't know that it necessarily needs
to be a recommendation to council
um because i think that is actually
already covered under delegated
authority
for officers carry out as a matter of
course uh
jan could you comment upon that or emily
sorry chair would be emily ewell emily
monitor officer of course emily could
you comment upon that
thank you mr chairman um yes it's
actually a recommendation to the
constitution working group
that the committee would make and then
any um
changes that the constitution working
group decides are appropriate would then
be reported to full council for adoption
thank you that's much better phrased and
thank you very much so it's a
recommendation to the working group
uh that a review and i'm specifying at
this point
that the only the petition scheme be the
subject of that review
um it's not reasonable for us to ask for
a review of the entire constitution
on the basis of today's meeting all
right
so the petition scheme only
chair are you happy with that councillor
grandin
yes i'm happy with that thank you
right chair let's see i'm just seeing
how my colleague
is getting on
mr chairman yes catherine osborne
i've looked at uh i looked at the the um
pieces that's up on yougov um
there are two areas there one is the pro
protocol and the other one is
the for going for um consideration
by by the offices of of that particular
petition scheme
are we are we voting on both of those or
just the one
the motion was to vote for
recommendation one and recommendation
two
right thank you the validation process
had been correctly followed
and was dealt with adequately and then
two
that the working party carried out a
review
of the petition scheme only thank you
very much
all right just waiting for that to
appear
yes voting
right i think that that covers it that
the council followed the validation
process correctly and that the petition
was dealt with adequately
and the numbering can be changed that
the weber overview and scrutiny
committee recommends to that
the constitution working group petition
scheme only to be reviewed
and recommendation be reported to full
council updated in line with comments
made
at this committee yes does that meet
members requirements
for a valid motion to vote upon
i believe so members can you please vote
i think the vote is in progress at the
moment i can see people are voting
chair that is six votes four
thank you very much so that is unanimous
uh that would close the meeting
but before we do i'd just like to add a
point in summary and i think it's
relevant for mr morelli
i hope you'll still hear mr morelli
and it's just a specific point regarding
the
purpose of any petition scheme and one
of the purposes of a petition scheme is
to raise a matter
in the public interest and to draw
people's attention
to that matter and in all three regards
you've done that
all three of those points have been
discussed have been debated
and have been considered and the length
of time
that these matters have been dealt with
in various ways because they are
actually different matters
your points have been taken on board and
they have influenced the nature of the
decisions that have been made
and in some cases will be made so in
that sense
your petition has achieved one of the
main purposes
that of drawing public attention you're
to be commended for the massive amount
of work you've done
if you're not going to go into the law
well there's always politics although
you would be well advised to steer clear
of that for the meantime
i just say thank you very much for your
efforts and on behalf of the committee
and uh i hope at any point in the future
you have any queries you bring them to
us
so thank you very much everybody for the
meeting uh we'll now close the meeting
and thank all members for their
attendance for the uh members
thank you
you